So we started out this course using functions. In
lesson one, we built a couple of different projects. Then,
we came across a scenario where using functions didn't
quite work really well. This was when we were trying
to build a movie website. This led us to
lesson two, where we were introduced two classes and we
built a bunch of different projects using classes. Here in
lesson three we will write our very first class, and
we will return to our movie website example. Let's begin. Now the
output of the program we are about to build will look a
little bit like this. A movie website with all of your favorite
movies,.and if you click on one of them its trailer will play.
[MUSIC]
Let's build this.